as promised I'm going to be delving more
into video game reviews and so I picked
up the evil within because I'm a big fan
of horror I do like survival horror
games when they're done well I am a huge
fan of the Resident Evil games some of
them not so much and we are not going to
talk about the Resident Evil movies in
this game you play as a detective named
Sebastian who is investigating he
doesn't even know what he's
investigating he discovers some dead
bodies with his partner then the ground
starts to cave underneath him and the
entire city splits in half and all of a
sudden there's zombies walking around
and a strange guy who's able to reappear
and disappear whenever he wants the
thing that I really liked about the evil
within is that it is not just a zombie
shoot-'em-up game there is a definite
psychological aspect to it psychological
horror films are my favorite type of
horror films so the fact that this game
has a lot of mind-bending suspense to it
I really enjoyed that aspect of this
game also the game has a great sense of
visual storytelling there's a lot that's
cinematic about this game for one it's a
235 aspect ratio instead of 185 like
most games so it does feel more
cinematic than a lot of games but about
that visual storytelling there was one
aspect of the game that really stuck out
to me I walked into a room this wasn't
important it wasn't a cutscene but there
was a dead body on the ground and
there's a lot of zombified bodies on the
ground throughout this game but this one
was human there were bullet holes all
over the wall things were turned over
and then a table was turned on its side
just that one little area told you
everything you needed to know that this
guy had a last stand in this room and
everyone took him out and he wasn't able
to make it this was not an imperative
part of the game you weren't supposed to
know anything about this guy he was just
a dead body but walking into that room
and seeing that visual storytelling
is the kind of stuff you do get in the
production design of this game that is
terrific you're walking through dark
corridors with a lantern and there's all
this dust floating around makes you feel
like you're walking through the ash of
humanity also really cool about this
game is when you upgrade yourself you
visit some otherworldly place and then
you put on this helmet and you upgrade
your abilities through electric shock
therapy it's kind of crazy and that's my
best way to describe this game it's
different it's really weird and it will
put you off kilter if you get into it
the controls are easy enough to learn
it's a fun enough game to
play it is more hard than you might
think and also a lot longer than I
thought it was gonna be it took me a lot
longer to complete this game than I
thought I would you have just enough
ammo you know like it's not like you're
scrounging for things and you're like
dying every two seconds because you're
running a bullets if you are
conservative with what you find you'll
be fine in the game and that's one of
the things I like about it cuz there is
combat in the game it's not just hiding
from zombies and hoping they don't kill
you that being said the main character
is boring as hell the only way you can
learn anything about him is by picking
up these documents that tell a story of
his pass-through journal entries and if
you don't read them you don't know
anything about them in fact most of the
characters in the game are really boring
especially this boy Leslie that you're
supposed to care about who is like a
patient he's going nuts and you follow
him around and find him some places and
you're supposed to care about him but he
just gets annoying after a while
and there are moments in the game that
are like unreasonably hard there's this
guy with a safe head and all this barbed
wire around him he took me forever and
there is a freaking spider grudge ring
girl who won't die I set that thing on
fire like 60 times she won't die there
were also moments when it's hard to tell
when a cutscene ends and the actual game
begins so because of that I didn't
realize I could control my character and
died quite often during a few parts
because the entire game is filmed in 235
aspect ratio as I said or in most games
when a cutscene starts maybe the 235
will starts and then as soon as you have
gameplay control again it'll go back to
185 which tells you okay now I can
control my character there were a lot of
times in this game where a cutscene ends
and then you immediately have to run
away from something well I didn't even
realize I could do that yet and I died
and then I realized oh I have control my
character after like 20 times of dying
there were also times where the textures
on the graphics appeared to be loading
for like a split second every time a
shot is cut and then we go to the next
shot and you see like certain things in
the background kind of load into
existence but the difficulty of the box
head man was made completely fine when
the trophy I got for defeating him was
called what's in the box that made
everything better and it also told me
what this game is trying to do it's
almost tributing so many awesome horror
movies
horror games that we've played before I
enjoy the evil within quite a bit it has
a great atmosphere as I said you're
walking through a strange mental
hospital and TVs are just showing static
you're walking through a creepy mansion
you can hear a girl laughing in the
background just really creepy stuff that
can unsettle you like that it can get a
little too difficult sometimes and
frustrating sometimes the camera gets
stuck behind things and none of the
characters are interesting at all but
when you play a game you want to have
some fun and overall I really enjoyed
playing the evil within I think it's
worth your time but I do have to say
that I know this game was very
anticipated for a lot of people it
really wasn't for me I didn't realize
until I actually picked it up that so
many people were excited about this game
so I think maybe if you were like oh my
gosh this is going to be the best horror
video game ever made you'll be
disappointed I was just looking forward
to a fun scary suspenseful game and I
got that so I'm gonna give the evil
within an eight out of ten
as promised guys I will continue to do
more video game reviews because a lot of
you guys are really enjoying it and I
like to talk about games I've been a
gamer my whole life so thanks as always
for watching guys and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
my next